so the future of video games may not be
in movies but is the future of movies in
video games who wouldn't want a
first-person version of Fifty Shades of
Grey I mean what
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the shameless do a crossover with myself
to make sure that people know about my
new channel episode okay so we all know
that video game movies have a reputation
for being awful and in case you missed
that episode where I talk about it over
on game theory how oh this is a brand
new channel and that is not a brand new
channel so the odds of you seeing this
video first is like zero anyway
obligatory annotation to that other
video go basically we theorized that
when they're not being exploited by
awful people for awful reasons video
game adaptations fail because of
converting an interactive medium into a
passive one you lose a core part of the
experience self-discovery something gets
lost in translation
it'd be like adapting the next divergent
book into I don't know a car instead of
another totally mediocre movie seriously
insurgent I had such high hopes for you
and I'm not even a tweenage girl easy to
make that mistake though totally
understandable but what have we switched
our focus instead of trying to make
games more cinematic or into actual
cinema that can even qualify what if we
instead tried to make movies more like
games what if there was legitimately a
way to get around all the problems
between the two mediums and make the
movie watching experience truly
interactive what if we could actually
make you part of the movie in the same
way that you're the protagonist of a
videogame it would make all those
moments you wanted to participate in at
the movies
put them right at your fingertips space
travel car chases the entirety of Willy
Wonka seriously drinking a chocolate
river guys how does that not become a
real theme park yet right but matpat I
hear you say we're already bringing
people closer to movies look at all the
3d movies out there and yes in a way
you're right there have actually been
tons of attempts even going back way out
before 3d movies to make films more
interactive with the audience the truth
is though those attempts haven't been
all that successful and the reasons why
are pretty fascinating so before we get
to the future of movies I'm gonna take
you back to the past like some other
guys some of
you guys might recognize and take a
brief spin through the history of
interactive cinema interactive movies
got their start even before movies had
sound ladies and gentlemen I present to
you
smell-a-vision the first-ever
interactive movie going experience
basically they would use electric fans
to blow a smell out over the audience or
go up to the balcony and spray a bunch
of perfume down on everyone the problem
was that even though things smelled
right during the movie it kept on
smelling after the movie for days it
clung to everything replacing the
theaters smell of artificial butter
substitute with the smell of things like
Chewbacca and believe it or not but
people weren't too keen on going home
smelling of wet Wookiee plus spraying
all that perfume was really expensive
Walt Disney wanted to include
smell-a-vision in Fantasia but scrapped
the idea because it was too costly
you know if Walt Disney didn't have
enough money to afford it well then good
luck to anyone else needless to say this
bad played itself out over time the next
interactive film experience came in the
form of the Kino automat a Czech
production from Expo 67 in Montreal it
was kind of like the World's Fair except
in Canada don't you know we're at 9
predetermined points throughout the
movie it would pause someone would come
out on stage and ask the audience what
scene they wanted to see next the
audience would then vote and the next
scene would play well we don't think of
it as being super high-tech now it was
one of the first-ever examples of a
choose your own adventure style movie
even Hollywood became interested in the
idea of the Kino auto man but because
the Czech were under communism at the
time the film was owned by the communist
governments who refused to work with the
West in any way shape or form and the
idea just kind of faded away 15 years
later a company named Advanced Micro
Computer Systems and annex Disney
animator gob Bloo I mean Don Bluth came
at the problem from a different angle
the video game angle in 1983 they made a
new super hi-tech laserdisc arcade game
dragon's lair which somehow managed to
be both a really boring movie and a
Nayan playable video game winning on
both fronts there guys on the surface
Dragon's Lair seemed to be just an
average animated
rescue the princess story that happened
to be on a smaller screen and you
watched standing up the thing was unless
you hit certain keystrokes during the
movie like an attack button or pressing
a directional key at the right time you
would lose the game aspect and the whole
weird movie video thing would end it was
like QuickTime events except you had no
indication of what to do or win
seriously if you actually wanted to see
the ending of this game you literally
had to repeat the middle parts of it
like dozens of times before you finally
figured it out got it right imagine
having to rewatch the middle 18 dates of
the movie 50 first dates like 12 times
that's like 180 dates with Adam Sandler
no one no one deserves that
now don't get me wrong this was actually
a pretty popular game for a while in the
mid 80s and eventually became kind of a
classic but only for the novelty and
definitely not for the compelling game
Bob I died again anyway things after
that when kind of silent for a while
except for some cutscene heavy games
like Metal Gear Solid and heavy rain and
terrible first attempts at virtual
reality like the 1995 Victor max cyber
max which unex is in its name that's how
you know it came from the 90s things lay
pretty dormant for the next 30 years
then miraculously about three years ago
the wounds left by Nintendo's Virtual
Boy finally healed and virtual reality
suddenly became relevant again everyone
from Facebook to Sony to Samsung to
valve are now into VR systems most of
them focusing on headsets in your choice
of unfashionable clunkiness would you
prefer the binoculars strapped to your
face or the Georgy LaForge visor the
pace car in this race has been oculus VR
but a big new player on the block has
been YouTube with their own 360-degree
camera compatibility it's the first
example of a major online platform
working this kind of technology into a
place where it could be used by
small-time filmmakers but at the same
time leaving lots of opportunity to
build it into big Hollywood blockbusters
and major video game publishers Google's
even got its own parallel product a VR
system made out of cardboard that you
then stick your cellphone into for like
five bucks I tried it out a couple
months ago and it's awesome
it just needs to come with some sort of
strap so I can pull down to like popcorn
and I don't know a diet coke you know
just as an example of a sample beverage
I could potentially be holding but all
of this technology for is awesome and
inspiring as it is brings up an
important question about what we define
as a movie movies are defined by a
director pointing a camera at some scene
and putting it on the screen in essence
deciding what the audience is looking at
for how long they look at it how closely
they look at it and all those small
details then deciding how that scene
fits into the hundreds of other scenes
to tell one overarching story but what
happens when the director no longer has
that control when the viewer instead
decides what to look at and what
sequence to watch things in or better
yet when you can watch a movie but then
turn your back on the main action and
instead choose to watch something
happening in the background something
that the 360-degree camera just happened
to capture the whole time that's what VR
technology is making possible but is
that still a movie or because the viewer
has control is it actually a video game
nope no it's it's not it's neither a
movie or a video game we're an
incredibly exciting time where we're
seeing the birth of a new form of
entertainment one that finds a middle
ground between movies and video games
one where the director and the audience
work together to create a new
entertainment experience the director
choosing the world in which to drop the
audience and then crafting what happens
in it but the audience ultimately
shaping their own story within that
world by watching what most interests
them it's an experience that's not
entirely driven by player choice like a
video game but it's also not entirely a
director's vision like a movie someone
called go tanks because it's a fusion of
the two movies video games
you John ha but you know me I'm not
happy leaving it there this VR
technology is the next step in
entertainment but I can take it one step
further the future of entertainment both
videogames and movies alike isn't just
about dropping you into a world and
giving you agency in it it's about fully
immersing you in that world we've
already mentioned 3d movies but anyone
who's ever been to a theme park has
probably experienced a 4d movie where
the seats Rumble and Shake in time with
the motion on the screen water jets
shoot out wind blows lights flash and
air bursts shoot out of your seat to
simulate bullets flying past your head
even smellivision has made its
triumphant return as sense gets squirted
out to let you truly get a whiff of that
fast and furious burning rubber but now
it's not just in amusement parks more
and more movie theaters are specially
equipping themselves with 4dx
experiences so what we have currently
are two separate experiences VR
technology allowing you to get a visual
experience as though you're actually in
the world and 40x theatres which give
you a more visceral experience of
actually being in the world so think
what would happen if you combine the two
well you don't have to because people
have already started to couple those two
ideas together resulting in immersion
experiences ones like Game of Thrones
ascend the wall where virtual reality
wind machines elevators and rumble pacts
take the user through the innards of
Castle black and up all 700 feet of the
wall where you can then walk around on
top and look out over the north or if
you're not interested in snow and nudity
you can try out catatonic we're live
nurses dressed in uniforms from the
1940s assure participants into a rumble
effects enhanced wheelchair where they
use virtual reality - have you
experienced a horrific tour through a
derelict mental hospital I think I'll
take the beheadings thank you very much
there are even setups now that allow you
to experience flying like a bird where
you lie down and flap your wings your
eyes are the city around you and the
wind is actually blowing through your
hair it's awesome it's terrifying and
it's immersive think about all of this
the matrix was right the future of
entertainment is being dropped into
worlds as real as our own where you can
look around hear a clap of
they're few raindrops on your face all
while smelling the wet dog who just so
happens to be running past and it's a
world where you have choice what story
do I want to watch today should I be neo
or should I be the office drone do i
watch the action in front of me or do I
turn around and see what else is going
on you know how the first movies with
sound were called talkies well my loyal
theorists I think it's time that we set
the bar for a new generation
let's coin the term here these immersive
experiences that you're gonna see
popping up over the next couple years
let's name them right now as choozy's
get it talkies choozy's choose Imams
choose Jeff I don't know I think it's
cute judge it if you will I think it's
catchy and it's a whole lot better than
immersive experiences okay VR alternate
reality experiences are they movies well
kinda but no are they video games again
kinda but no but are they unlike
anything the world has yet experienced
you bets but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and cuts first off please
subscribe similar to milk it does a body
good plus you found this video in the
first place meaning that you're probably
a fan of game theory to begin with so
help me make this new channel a success
that being said welcome back to the
super amazing end card tournament where
today's question is a simple one are you
excited about the prospect of VR film
experiences do you want to control the
way you view a movie or would you just
prefer sitting back and watching things
happen on the screen I know for me it's
a little bit of 50-50 I'm excited about
the idea of a choose my own adventure
style movie experience but I also love
having all those decisions made for me
you know anyway I'm curious to get your
opinion click on one to choose and tune
in next time to find out what everyone
thought and subscribe seriously I know
I'm sounding like a broken record but
wouldn't it be super awesome if we could
somehow get this channel to like a
million subscribers and record time that
would be incredible but I can't do it
without you guys
so my fate is in your hands now if
you'll excuse me I got to go work on
another one of these film theories so
we're ready for launch see cuz I'm
filming this now but this is you
watching it in the future so rest
assured all the videos you see on the
film Theory Channel right now those are
ones that have been months in
process I'm thinking of you guys